the SCP Foundation specializes in
tracking down and containing anomalies
that are difficult to find and that
often will do anything they can to avoid
being found one anomaly in particular
hates being seen more than anything and
will punish anyone who looks at its face
with a horrific fate
scp-096 is a mysterious creature not
only because it destroys anyone who sees
what it truly looks like no one is
entirely certain where it came from what
exactly it is or why it reacts so
violently to being perceived there are
however several theories as to the Shy
Guy's origin and none of them are
particularly cheerful some suggest an
experiment gone wrong others believe it
to be the last remaining member of an
unknown species of mountain dwelling
humanoids well one theory about
scp-096's origin stands out as
particularly tragic in nature in this
story SC p096 was not always a long
limbed pale Beast cowering in the corner
and hiding its face from the world it
was once an ordinary man like anyone you
might pass on the street he was
someone's son someone's friend a person
with hopes dreams and passions a human
being who through anomalous
circumstances Beyond his control was
made into a monster many years ago there
was a mountaineer named Jack all his
adult life he had been obsessed with
reaching higher and higher Peaks
climbing Every Mountain he could in
order to test his limits hid himself
against the power of nature and bask in
the sweet reward that was the view from
the top it began as a sport a way to
build up strength while taking in
incredible natural beauty but over time
as he conquered increasingly difficult
challenges it became an obsession like
every Obsession eventually does climbing
mountains began to take over his life
driving everything else away he
struggled to hold down a job his
marriage fell apart and his
relationships to his friends and family
became increasingly distant and strained
still he couldn't bring himself to care
much he spent his alone time in the
wilderness or every so often embarking
on trips with other Mountaineers whether
he was going at it Solo or working with
others he was living for the climb over
the years he took on cerotore in
Argentina Diego in Switzerland and
Denali in Alaska he especially enjoyed
climbing an extreme cold raving the ice
and snow as he embarked on his climbs
the few fellow Mountaineers he kept up
with gave him the nickname Jack Frost
after years of refining his craft
building his strength he set his sights
on the highest mountain in the world his
personal white whale Mount Everest
itself it was one of the deadliest
climbs in the world with its staggering
height storms and Frozen graveyard of
Fallen climbers dotting the snow always
surface but he was determined he would
not join the ranks of the Fallen but
instead be one of the Victorious that
reached the top of Everest and came back
down in one piece he could feel it in
his bones Jack arrived in Nepal with a
pack full of climbing equipment the best
boots money could buy and layers upon
layers of clothing to keep himself warm
on the journey to the summit he lowered
his goggles over his eyes summoned his
courage and prepared for the incredibly
difficult climb the cold seeped into his
core the wind snipped at his face
numbing his nose and leeching through
his gloves and boots as he went but Jack
pressed on he welcomed the sensation the
bite of it it was a reminder that he was
still here that he was still alive as
long as he could feel the pain he knew
he was alright he knew that it was when
the cold faded away turned to
paradoxical feelings of warmth and
sleepiness that a mountaineer was truly
in trouble as he navigated the harsh
mountain landscape Jack occasionally let
his eyes drift off course taking in the
sights around him he could see shocks of
blue green and red the distant bright
colors of boots jackets and hats
belonging to the Fallen climbers that
came before him those who collapse from
exhaustion who gave in to altitude
sickness or succumbed to the cold
Memento Mori he said softly to himself
these frozen bodies represented that
ever-present reminder of mortality of
death lurking just out of sight it would
not come for him though not today not on
this journey he wouldn't let it the
hours blurred together within the crunch
of the ice beneath his boots the Dig of
climbing hooks into the Earth the tug of
his trusty ropes as he ascended ever
higher Jack came to a stop there was no
next step to tank nowhere higher that he
could go he had reached the summit the
white whale was captured and Everest was
his for the very first time he was truly
on top of the world now that he had made
it to the highest point there was the
all-important task of climbing back down
at this altitude he was still in the
death zone the place where human
acclimatization was impossible this was
the tricky part the point at which even
the most experienced of climbers might
get lost in the Euphoria of the
achievement and might let their
attention slip any mistake during his
dissent any misstep could be the thing
that cost him his life there was no room
for error and no time to waste just as
Jack prepared to make his descent he saw
a figure pulling itself over the ridge
from a distance it looked like a fellow
climber he noticed the Curious lack of
equipment and the way the person seemed
to be making their way up the mountain
with nothing but their hands but perhaps
they lost their pack or left it behind
for some reason the figure was dressed
in all white from their Hood to their
boots with a large pair of Black
Mountain goggles covering what little of
their face wasn't concealed by the hood
uncertain if the figure was in need of
assistance and surprised to see another
Soul on the mountain with him jack waved
at the figure everything okay he called
there was no response but the figure
turned to look at him at least he
thought it was looking at him he
couldn't see its eyes through the
goggles but he felt the distinct
sensation of it locking its gaze with
his just the same as soon as the figure
turned to look at him jack began to feel
strange the pain the sharp sensation of
the cold that he relied on to ground
himself and remember he was really here
began to blur around the edges the
feeling softened melting away along with
the ache in his muscles the blurriness
in his eyes the dry mouth that had
nagged at him for hours he felt
unbalanced unmoored a ship with no
anchor he couldn't explain why
a sudden relief from the cold made his
chest tightened with Primal Terror he
did not feel like one man encountering
another on the mountain he felt the way
he had years ago when he came face to
face with a mountain lion staring down a
predator and remembering all of a sudden
that humans do not naturally sit at the
top of the food chain this figure this
thing it was no man it was no person
Jack prepared to continue his descent to
get away from the strange Intruder as
quickly as possible but his feet would
not obey him his eyes cannot break
contact with the figure in white that
was slowly beginning to advance toward
him one slow step at a time it was in no
hurry it knew he was not going anywhere
anytime soon he trembled as the figure
grew closer its inscrucible face hidden
beneath its hood and behind its goggles
he wished he could just see its face but
dreaded learning What secrets it was
hiding if only he could just unstick his
feet from the earth Break Free of this
spell that had fallen over him he could
Escape but no matter how much his
muscles strained how he gritted his
teeth with effort he couldn't get away
as the entity came closer the cold
snapped back into his body but something
was different it was heightened like
every icy Breeze and freezing wind
layered on top of itself hardening his
muscles to rock crystallizing the very
blood in his veins he felt as if his
fingers if he tried to wriggle them
would snap off and fall to the ground
his eyes thrummed in their sockets his
lungs stretched to hold on to each
breath as the cold constricted its fist
around his chest he opened his mouth to
speak but his voice died in his throat
coming out in a weak Whisper of air now
the thing was close enough to touch him
and whatever Force had been holding him
still and upright released him it was as
if he were a marionette to suspend it in
the air and the Puppeteer released his
strings at once he crumpled to the
snow-covered ground in a heap his cheek
pressed into the Earth his eyes trained
helplessly on the still advancing figure
his lip formed the word please though he
could not tell exactly what he was
begging for his life his freedom a
painless death perhaps he struggled to
push himself to his feet but all the
strength had gone out of his limbs he
could barely lift his arm let alone
handle the weight of his whole body the
thing shaped like a man was right above
him glowing down through those opaque
goggles he still could not see its eyes
but somehow he could feel the way it was
looking at him hatred was radiating off
of it disdain and pure unadulterated
malice then it tilted its head to the
side thoughtfully and Jack's mind was
overwhelmed with images he felt the
Phantom sensation of sunlight on his
skin and spring green grass beneath his
bare feet he could see clear as day in
his Mind's Eye a forest in the middle of
summer dewdrops sparkling on the Petals
of wildflowers blowing in a gentle sweet
Breeze then he felt sand between his
toes smelled the Sea Breeze felt the
comfort and contentment of a nap on the
beach it was not offering these things
to him but something like them something
like peace it was offering him a gift
but he didn't want it he couldn't take
it he was Jack Frost damn it he thrived
in the cold the hardship he didn't want
some warm sleepy Fade Out of existence
if he went out it would be on his terms
doing the thing he had dedicated his
life to if he were going to lose his
life he wouldn't roll over and just give
it up it would need to be Pride from his
Frozen hands with every last bit of
strength he twisted his head away from
the entity's Gaze covering his face with
his hands it grabbed at him shaking his
shoulders trying to force him to uncover
his face and meet its gaze once more but
he didn't budge he wouldn't he couldn't
then he felt the energy shift as it
realized he had refused the gift that he
would not welcome the paradoxical
feelings of heat and security and slip
away as it was asking him to but it was
not a victory he swore he could hear a
voice in his mind saying
very
well be part of the mountain
I will make it so the world went white
as Jack's eyes rolled back in his head
his spine curving back until it snapped
his jaw cracked and distended his arms
and legs stretched out long and twisted
his body contorted at unnatural angles
as the entity began to rearrange his
very being as the agony ripped through
him snapping his bones and tearing his
muscles Jack kept his face cradled in
his hands he remained in that position
even as he cried his voice hoarse as the
pure fear and pain overwhelmed his
senses until he forgot his own name for
God he was ever a man at all when Jack
was no more when something else sat
there in his place pale and shivering
body racked with sobs the king of the
mountain turned and left him there alone
with his misery still he would not
uncover his face he would not let
himself be vulnerable and would not book
God Days Later a group of Mountaineers
reached the summit of Everest and
spotted the hair careless figure
crouched in the snow weeping softly are
you all right one of them asked the
figure lifted its head slowly and locked
eyes with the strangers its eyes widened
in horror its mouth stretched impossibly
wide in a wordless scream of rage and
hurt and with nothing human left in its
mind or heart
scp-096 took its very first victim now
go check out scp-096 Shy Guy Escape
incident
096-1-a Containment Breach and how our
bodies actually Frozen on Mount Everest
scp-1529 King of the mountain for more
on the players in today's harrowing
video